pas le regarder vos tableaux dans un
instant mais un commentaire sur
statistique canada qu'est ce qui se
passe pourquoi on a de plus en plus de
difficultés à se fier à ces chiffres et
là vous savez historiquement la collecte
de données se fait par sondage
téléphonique moi je me questionne sur la
validité des données qui proviennent
uniquement d'un sondage téléphonique en
2014 peut-être qu'il y aurait moyen de
faire un peu comme l'expérience
américaine où on publie deux sondages
au même moment un sondage auprès des
entreprises qui est un sondage papier de
façon à mieux cerner les tendances au
marché du travail mais je doute de plus
en plus de la robustesse des données qui
sont colligées par un sondage
téléphonique allons voir donc le premier
tableau